merci d'être avec nous Florence bletre
et compta et de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure cette élue de
lin donc du groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain ici au Sénat on va parler
de la proposition de la des socialistes
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
un mot sur l'actualité on l'a vu dans le
journal elisabeth a rencontré hier les
syndicats sur la réforme des retraites
alors tous sont opposés au report de
l'âge légal de départ comme maintient le
gouvernement sans qu'on sache si c'est
64 ou 65 ans est-ce que pour vous c'est
consultations sont utiles il est
toujours de
utile de consulter les syndicats mais
encore faut-il les écouter les syndicats
ont été unanimes sur le refus de la
mesure d'augmentation de l'âge légal et
pour autant le gouvernement n'entend pas
renoncer donc nous sommes nous aussi
mais d'ailleurs comme la grande majorité
des Français opposés à un report de
l'âge légal de la retraite c'est une
réforme brutale et qui pénaliserait
vraiment injuste parce qu'elle
pénaliserait ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler le plus tôt qui ont des
carrières longues
par exemple les ouvriers on le sait bien
ont un état un écart d'espérance de vie
de 7 ans avec les cadres et pousser
l'âge légal à 65 ans serait
particulièrement injuste pour eux vous
pensez avoir les moyens de contrer cette
réforme au Parlement elle arrivera début
de 2023 au Parlement penser pour faire
reculer le gouvernement qui n'exclut pas
de passer par un projet de notre
sécurité et donc par un 49-3 non alors
là franchement passé sur un 49,3 sur la
réforme des retraites ce serait vraiment
on comprend que sur le budget le
gouvernement n'ayant pas n'ayant qu'une
majorité relative passe par un 49-3 même
si huit 49,3 ça commence à être beaucoup
je crois qu'il y avait une volonté
d'annoncer à annoncer de de ce concerter
de travailler plus collectivement après
ce renouvellement de l'assemblée on voit
bien que ça n'a pas lieu et franchement
je crois que c'est un risque énorme que
prendrait le président de la République
parce que les Français n'admettraient
pas que sur ce sujet le 49-3 soit
utilisé quel est votre position parce
que la nuque défend la retraite à 60 ans
mais le PS a longtemps défendu en
maintien de l'âge légal de départ à 62
ans qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre
alors tout d'abord la retraite à 60 ans
existe François Hollande qui l'avait
institué pour ceux qui ont des carrières
longues et donc qui ont commencé à
travailler
avant 20 ans donc pour cela la retraite
à 60 ans existe nous espérons qu'elle
sera maintenue en tout état de cause
mais pour ceux qui ont commencé après 20
ans avec des 42 ans depuis dans quelques
années 43 ans de cotisations et bien
l'âge de départ finalement n'est déjà
plus 60 ans mais il est 62 ans et je
crois que sur 2021 l'âge moyen de départ
à la retraite est de 63 ans donc pour
moi en fait il n'y a pas de sujet
là-dessus la retraite à 60 ans existe
déjà pour ceux qui défendent la retraite
à 60 ans pour tous c'est une aberration
pour vous non je dirais pas que c'est
une aberration mais en tout état de
cause c'est pas votre position c'est pas
ma position je crois que notre premier
secrétaire a dit que ça pouvait être un
objectif à long terme en tout cas
aujourd'hui c'est ce n'est pas tenable
donc moi je voilà nous sommes
responsables et en tout état de cause
c'est pas notre position dans l'immédiat
et je crois que cette position est
partagée
l'inquiétude des Français en ce moment
elle se porte aussi sur les coupures
d'électricité qui pourrait avoir lieu
après Noël est-ce que le gouvernement a
eu raison d'alerter dès maintenant et de
préparer un plan en cas de coupure
il a eu les raisons disons qu'il le fait
dans la cacophonie je vous rappelle que
au mois de juin le président de la
République indiquait je veux vous
rassurer il n'y a aucun risque de
coupure d'électricité parce que il y a
des besoins on s'approvisionne sur le
marché européen donc on voit bien que on
a l'impression de repartir comme au
début du covid dans la cacophonie la
plus totale certains ministres évoquent
les délaissage puis le président de la
République est en colère parce que des
ministres évoqués des stages pansements
franchement là encore c'est la
cacophonie
que ça et c'est quand même indispensable
vraiment de travailler avec tous ceux
qui pourraient être confrontés à ces
coupures il y a des inquiétudes hier
j'ai participé à la réunion avec la
préfète de mon département donc il y a
vraiment des inquiétudes
quels sont les inquiétudes à l'heure les
inquiétudes des élus je elles sont au
nombre de de trois enfin essentiellement
ce que j'ai ressenti hier il y a tout
d'abord la question des du recensement
des personnes a besoin vitaux des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
elle a les communes devront sans doute
compléter leur fichier parce que il
faudra agir sur ces personnes là et puis
il y a la question des antennes
téléphoniques qui ne fonctionneront plus
et du fonctionnement du 112 avec des
zones blanches dans lesquelles le 112 ne
fonctionne pas plus donc les
collectivités sont invités à faire un
accueil de ceux qui auraient des
difficultés mais pour autant le
elles n'auront peut-être elles-mêmes pas
accès aux 112 et il y a un sujet qui
inquiète qui m'inquiète tout
particulièrement j'ai été pendant 10 ans
vice-président d'un syndicat d'eau
potable c'est les coupures pour les
structures d'eau potable de traitement
d'eau potable et de traitement d'eau
usées parce que s'il y a une pollution
s'il y a un déversement donc moi
j'invite vraiment l'État à travailler
avec les collectivités qui gèrent ces
structures pour vraiment prévenir tous
les risques pour moi c'est essentiel il
faut anticiper là dessus on va passer à
l'actualité puisqu'il y a les sénateurs
examinés entre autres une proposition de
loi socialiste pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux le texte a été rejeté
en séance on va voir les temps forts de
cette séance avec Quentin Calmet
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour Florence Bertrix
socialiste dans leur viseur un sujet
récurrent pour le Sénat la lutte contre
les déserts médicaux voilà ça fait
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois que
l'on parle de cette problématique
qu'elle revient sur le devant de
l'actualité un mot tout d'abord sur le
constat dans les départements Oriane
parce que même avec la fin du numerus
clausus qui a été acté et bien la
démocratie la démographie médicale elle
va mettre plusieurs années peut-être 10
ans ça a été dit en séance hier pour
rééquilibrer les besoins en médecins sur
le terrain elle a Caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie a chiffré en cette
dégradation de la situation dans les
départements on parle d'une densité
médicale pour les généralistes qui a
diminué de 18% sur 20 ans contre 9% sur
les autres spécialités et on parle donc
de 5000 généralistes en moins entre 2010
et 2021 on va voir aussi la densité dans
les départements sur une carte avec la
densité de ces médecins rapportés à
100000 habitants c'est une carte de 2021
le centre de la France mais aussi l'île
de France tout autour de Paris il y a
des voilà des endroits qui sont
particulièrement sous dotés mais on le
voit il y en a en fait un peu partout un
des déserts médicaux en tout cas des des
besoins médecins généralistes il y a
donc un consensus pour dire qu'il faut
remédier à la situation mais des
différences dans les solutions à
apporter au problème avait déjà adopté
un texte qui venait des républicains
alors quelle est la différence avec le
texte d'hier et le gouvernement aussi
également eu cette même idée dans le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale ça a été examiné il y a
quelques semaines l'idée pour tout le
monde c'est de rallonger d'une année
l'internat des étudiants dans la
spécialité de médecine générale d'autant
que cette médecine générale elle fait
figure d'exception avec une durée du
diplôme d'études spécialisées de
seulement trois ans par rapport aux 43
autres spécialités qui sont organisées
sur quatre à six années alors
spécifiquement la proposition de loi
examinée hier prévoit de doter
obligatoirement les zones soudances et
pas en priorité comme voulait les LR de
plus le texte socialiste prévoit des
modalités spécifiques de rémunération
des internes concernés par cette
obligation écoutez c'était donc hier
soir en séance
ne sera donc pas un simple stage et sera
et ces modalités de mise en oeuvre et en
particulier une rémunération spécifique
à la hauteur de leur parcours seront
négociées et j'insiste sur ce terme de
négocier avec toutes les parties
prenantes et en particulier les
organisations syndicales des étudiants
de troisième cycle voilà ce texte a été
rejeté hier en séance 203 voix contre
100 voix pour la droite était contre ce
texte des socialistes écoutez Philippe
mouillé cette proposition de loi arrive
trop tôt parce que la concertation entre
les professionnels de santé et les
pouvoirs publics dont nous avons parlé
et toujours en cours et elle arrive trop
tard parce qu'elle reprend les débats
que nous avons déjà eu
comme mes collègues du groupe LR je ne
voterai contre cette proposition de loi
est-ce que vous regrettez la position Dr
en séance ce texte il aurait pu parler
d'aller encore plus loin ou même de
remarquer à nouveau le besoin en
médecins dans les départements oui tout
à fait vous avez pu remarquer que du
côté des républicains hier les missiles
étaient quand même très vides et moi ce
que j'ai entendu de leur part c'est la
situation est très grave mais il y a
urgence à ne rien faire enfin bon
vraiment c'est pas acceptable je crois
que notre PPL offrait vraiment une
solution notre proposition de loi
offrait vraiment des solutions qui
perdent ne permettait pas de tout
résoudre mais qui permettait d'avancer
vers la résolution des problèmes parce
que vous avez évoqué la quatrième année
que nous proposons est différent de ce
qui a été proposé dans la proposition de
loi du Président retaillau c'est une
obligation sur cette activité quatrième
année de l'effectuer dans les zones
soudances donc ça change quand même
sensiblement les choses ça permet de
redensifier le territoire en médecins
donc c'était déjà le premier élément de
cette proposition de loi il y a un autre
élément moi qui me semble très important
c'est la régulation de l'installation
des médecins Vous avez très bien
démontrer dans la carte qu'il y a un
nombre de zones soudances très important
dans mon département on est
particulièrement concerné là était le
troisième je sais plus c'est toujours le
troisième mais dans les cinq
départements les moins bien dotés et
très franchement conjugais rencontrer
les élus de mon territoire souvent c'est
la première chose
qu'ils expriment cette vraiment cette
grande difficulté
il on a quand même 6 millions en France
de personnes qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant c'est inacceptable juste pour
qu'on comprenne bien il le texte donc
qui a déjà été adopté le texte de Bruno
dorotaïo Bruno vous venez de l'évoquer
le gouvernement aussi travaille sur ce
sujet on l'a dit dans le projet va de
financement de la sécurité sociale il y
avait une mesure comme cela où est-ce
qu'on en est aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce
que cette proposition de loi était
nécessaire selon vous vu qu'il y a déjà
tous ces processus qui sont en cours
parce que je vous l'ai dit sur la
question elle va vraiment plus loin sur
la 4e année c'est obligatoirement en
zone Soudan c'est quand même une
différence importante et moi vous savez
dans mon département je le vois bien je
suis à la
au croisement de deux métro Paul la
métropole genevoise la métropole
lyonnaise et on peine vraiment à attirer
des médecins dans ces territoires donc
cette quatrième année obligatoire est
essentielle et le conventionnement
sélectif attention c'est pas comme les
enseignants on ne dit pas aux médecins
vous allez vous installer à tel endroit
on lui dit simplement vous ne pouvez pas
aller dans une zone qualifiée de
surdence et en fait de ces zones
qualifiées de surdence c'est 20% du
territoire c'est pas beaucoup vous ne
pouvez aller dans ces zones que si vous
remplacez un médecin à la retraite
sachant que beaucoup vont partir à la
retraite donc voyez la contrainte n'est
pas très importante mais elle va
permettre de fluidifier et de
redensifier dans des zones comme mon
département et c'est essentiel vraiment
et c'est la différence principale parce
que on a beaucoup incité il y a eu
beaucoup de mécanismes maintenant selon
vous et ça n'est plus suffisant la
citation n'a pas marché un mot sur les
ce qu'on pense les médecins eux-mêmes
Quentin les syndicats des des étudiants
en médecine effectivement il s'opposent
depuis plusieurs mois à toutes ces
propositions toutes ces idées ils disent
que ça va faire perdre en attractivité
la spécialité de médecins généralistes
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez non
mais aujourd'hui on a vraiment besoin je
comprends les jeunes médecins on a en
France une culture de médecine libérale
elle est là mais là on est dans une
situation de détresse d'urgence je
rencontre des gens qui n'ont pas très de
médecins traitants depuis trois ans donc
vous leur dites il faut qu'ils prennent
leur temps à prendre sa part le temps
que le numéro clausus fasse effet une
petite une petite année et puis c'est ce
que je vous dis la contrainte n'est pas
extraordinaire dans ce qu'on propose
c'est le conventionnement sélectif
c'est-à-dire ne pas pouvoir s'installer
si ce n'est pour en remplacement de
médecin dans une zone sur dense donc la
contrainte est faible mais permettra je
crois que tout le monde doit faire des
efforts
vous l'avez dit aussi en séance je crois
c'est l'importance aussi d'accompagner
et ce sera au département si dans notre
proposition de là c'était au département
de le faire c'est très important aussi
que ces étudiants ne soient pas dans la
nature s'ils sont dans une soudain c'est
ça aussi vous l'avez pas tout à fait ils
doivent être accompagné par les départs
rémunéré on proposait pour cette
quatrième année une rémunération aux
alentours de 3500 euros donc c'est
davantage que les internes et c'est
indispensable c'est une meilleure
rémunération et un accompagnement des
départements des communautés de communes
aujourd'hui dans les herbes médicaux les
départements les communautés de communes
font déjà beaucoup
essaye d'attirer les jeunes médecins
merci Yann dans le club on va reparler
de la dernière ligne droite dans la
course à la présidence des LR ce sera
dans une demi-heure merci Quentin tout à
l'heure on va parler de commerce
extérieur Florence Blatterie contre
puisque vous avez remis hier un rapport
de la délégation sénatorielle aux
entreprises sur ce sujet l'année 2022
qui est sur le point de sèche-cheveux
avec un déficit historique du commerce
extérieur dans le budget 2023 le déficit
commercial devrait attendre 156
milliards d'euros c'est un peu moins du
double que celui de 2021 c'est un
problème conjoncturel qui est lié à
l'envolée des prix ou c'est un problème
qui est structurel en fait il y a les
deux il y a un problème structurel parce
que je crois que le dernier ex du
commerce extérieur date de 2002 donc
voyez bien qu'on a un problème
structurel évidemment aggraver cette
année par la crise énergétique puisque
c'est un de nos principaux postes de
dépendance donc évidemment cette année
la partie structurelle à aggraver le
déficit mais nous ce qui nous inquiète
évidemment c'est la tendance le conjo le
structurel la dégradation de notre
commerce extérieur depuis
une vingtaine d'années la perte de
compétitivité qui résulte de la
désindustrialisation que l'on a connu
comment on fait alors comment on fait
pour que ce commerce c'est possible que
ce commerce extérieur soit à nouveau
excédentaire
en tout cas il faut essayer en tout cas
on va pas passer de 150 milliards à un
excédent d'un jour à l'autre mais il
faut
essayer de retrouver de la souveraineté
économique de réindustrialiser notre
pays et aussi de se retrouver de ce
qu'on en économie des avantages
comparatifs vous voyez où est-ce qu'on a
nos excédents finalement le luxe
l'aéronautique
la chimie pharmacie met de moins en
moins donc il faut retrouver des
avantages compétitifs dans des domaines
par exemple on a perdu la bataille du
numérique est-ce qu'on l'a vraiment mené
en France on l'a perdu donc il faut
aussi
identifier des secteurs clés d'avenir et
investir dans ces secteurs clés d'avenir
et il faut aussi retrouver des
compétences il faut retrouver des
investissements et des compétences on va
aller voir l'actualité dans nos régions
maintenant on va aller du côté de Brive
retrouver pomme la brousse bonjour merci
d'être avec nous responsable de la
rédaction du journal La Montagne en
Corrèze et à l'occasion de la Coupe du
Monde pomme votre journal c'est
intéressé à l'argent cathari investi en
Corrèze et plus particulièrement dans
l'entreprise LE TANNEUR
effectivement je suis la responsable
adjointe on est une équipe multiple en
Corrèze et c'est vrai que avec cette
coupe du monde qui a fait couler
tendance nous en Corrèze on a choisi de
s'intéresser à ces investissements
kataris c'était l'occasion pour notre
journaliste Emilie Auffret de revenir
sur le rachat d'un maroquinier
d'excellence basé à bord les orgues
c'est une petite ville de presque 3000
habitants surtout connu pour son barrage
mon explique donc dans cet article
comment le fabricant historique de la
marque letaner a été racheté d'abord par
les catarians en 2011 puis par le groupe
français solomayi en 2017 alors détail
amusant les Qataris achètent donc le
tanneur en 2011 simplement quelques mois
après avoir obtenu l'organisation de la
coupe de du monde de football 2022 et à
l'époque sur le parking des ateliers de
Bort-les-Orgues on trace un cercle à la
peinture pour permettre un hélicoptère
de s'y poser mais la présidente de qlg
Qatar luxury blue la mère de l'actuel
Emir du Qatar n'est jamais venu
alors certes depuis que le meilleur a
repris les rênes c'était il y a 5 ans
que le meilleur a apporté son expertise
dans le domaine de la maroquinerie de
luxe mais ce qu'on sait peu en Corrèze
c'est que l'argent catharite n'a pas
disparu en réalité
QG est toujours actionnaire après ce que
40 % des
qatari ont notamment soutenu la
trésorerie pendant le covid et là on
parle en millions d'euros aujourd'hui
tolomeyy a créé près de 150 emplois
ouvert un nouvel atelier à une
quarantaine de kilomètres des premiers
et prévoit d'embaucher une centaine de
personnes sur les trois prochaines
années à terme ça ferait donc plus de
600 emplois sur ce secteur de du Nord
Corrèze qui est plutôt un secteur quand
même très rural d'où ma question madame
la sénatrice une question à rallonge un
petit peu pensez-vous qu'il y a un enjeu
de souveraineté dans le cadre de ses
savoir-faire de prestige qui sont
précieux pour notre pays vous avez parlé
du luxe qui nous permettait d'être
d'avoir une balance commerciale
excellente et puis cette histoire montre
que nombre de fonds étrangers même venus
d'un pays épinglé pour n'avoir pas
respecté les droits humains a été
crucial pour la poursuite de l'activité
et il est toujours d'ailleurs cette
histoire donc n'est-elle pas
l'illustration des difficultés
auxquelles on fait face en France
lorsqu'il s'agit d'assurer la reprise
d'activités essentielle pour certains
territoires
oui vous avez tout à fait raison la
question de la reprise d'entreprise et
celle-là m'intéresse tu particulièrement
parce qu'elle trouve son origine dans
mon département
l'entreprise de Tanor est née dans le
département de l'Ain et bien entendu il
y a une vingtaine d'années on a laissé
partir beaucoup de pépites comme ça qui
ont été rachetés par des capitaux
étrangers lors de nos auditions nous
avons auditionné en économiste qui nous
disait
puisque nous savons nous ne savons pas
vendre à l'étranger nous nous vendons et
c'est un peu l'histoire de que vous
évoquez ici donc il faut vraiment
travailler sur la reprise des
entreprises sur le maintien des
compétences parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
lorsque ces entreprises ont disparu
lorsque j'ai par exemple l'exemple d'une
d'une de quelqu'un qui veut créer une
entreprise dans le filage pour recréer
les bases ne retrouve pas de personnes
qualifiées et elle ne trouve même pas de
machine outils donc vous voyez quand on
a perdu l'outil productif quand on a
perdu les compétences et bien on perd
complètement ses industries qui partent
ailleurs donc il faut favoriser la
reprise des entreprises je crois que
depuis la mise en place du pacte du
trail il y a eu une prise de conscience
quand même et une amélioration dans ce
domaine-là des collègues au Sénat ont
produit un rapport sur la reprise des
entreprises propose ont proposé un
certain nombre de simplification
notamment dans les reprises une
information aussi aux dirigeants il faut
que quand ces entreprises ont des
besoins de capitaux on puisse trouver
une solution en France pour qu'elle
trouve des capitaux on a aujourd'hui des
structures de financement avec la BPI
notamment aujourd'hui on a davantage
d'outils qu'à l'époque je rappelle que
la BPI a été mise en place sous François
Hollande on a beaucoup plus
outils aujourd'hui pour pour ces
reprises d'entreprises qui sont
cruciales pour notre savoir-faire et
pour notre compétitivité
pendant le dernier mot on regarde votre
une
vous voulez qu'on montre la une on va la
regarder la une de la montagne Corrèze
les discrètes affaires du Qatar
encoreais c'était la Une de votre
journal ce matin merci beaucoup comme la
brousse d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
depuis Brive 20 derniers mots sur votre
partie le Parti socialiste en plein
congrès le Congrès final aura lieu à
Marseille ce sera le dernier week-end de
janvier mais bon là il y a trois motions
trois lignes en fait qui s'affrontent
une ligne pro nuque une ligne anti-up et
une ligne un peu en même temps qui ne
conteste pas l'accord mais qui n'est pas
sur la même ligne qu'Olivier Forkel quel
est votre quel est votre ligne à vous
quelle est la bonne ligne pour le PS de
demain alors tout d'abord je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose qu'il y a une
troisième ligne parce que on ne peut pas
avoir un troisième congrès avec
l'affrontement des mêmes lignes à chaque
fois on refait le match à chaque fois on
avance pas beaucoup donc il est utile
qu'il y a une troisième ligne et moi je
m'y suis engagée parce que vraiment il y
a un travail avec qui font fait un
travail collectif auprès de avec Nicolas
meilleur Rossignol on organise
je crois qu'on a aujourd'hui besoin de
retravailler dans notre partie vous
voyez on a des défis incroyables on a
inédit même on a la transition
écologique qui est vraiment un défi
énorme on a nos services publics qui
sont complètement à plat vous avez
évoqué l'hôpital mais il y a aussi
l'éducation nationale on a un rapport au
travail qui change on a une géopolitique
qui évolue donc ça nous oblige à
repenser le monde et il faut se remettre
au travail et c'est aussi pour cela que
je soutiens Nicolas meilleur Rossignol
je pense que pendant les cinq dernières
années on n'a pas assez travaillé sur le
fond on avait l'habitude d'avoir des
conventions c'est obligé fort oui en
effet je pense que le parti doit se
remettre au travail et c'est aussi pour
ça que j'ai soutenu Nicolas meilleur
doit quitter la tête du PS pour vous oui
je souhaite que évidemment la motion que
je soutienne l'emporte à ce congrès ça
peut avoir des conséquences sur le
groupe ici au Sénat non je ne pense pas
non non merci merci beaucoup Florence
cette première demeure dans 20 minutes
dans le coffre des territoires on ira à
Privas dans l'Ardèche dans une
entreprise de fabrication de marron
glacés puisque c'est bientôt Noël
fabrication française évidemment mais
d'abord on va accueillir notre prochaine
invité c'est Mathias